In 1977, I met a French chef.
He said to me, "Cooks
cook to nurture people."
That moment is when I decided
to become a professional chef.
It's an emotional
connection that you
have to have with food,
first and foremost.
This is the first time I've
ever done anything like this.
I've always felt that we
are a product of those
who have inspired us.
I stand on the shoulders
of countless chefs
who came before me.
I have better knowledge, I have
better skills because of them.
And that's my job,
to pass it on.
I focus on techniques,
rather than recipes,
because it's really
the techniques that
are the most important
part of any recipe.
Salt enhances, acid enhances,
pepper changes flavor
or adds another flavor.
The amount of oil that a yoke
will take is almost infinite.
Glazing is surprisingly
challenging, even
for professional cooks.
The aromas, the sound
is really important.
Any one of these
techniques is something
that I know is achievable.
Every technique that
I'm sharing with you,
we use in our restaurants.
We want to give you
very simple dishes
with very few ingredients.
It really ignites that
emotional connection to food.
So pan roasting is a technique
to give you creamy, almost
pudding-like zucchini.
If you go through the steps,
if you take your time,
if you're patient,
you will succeed.
Everything here
that I'm teaching
is something that will
last you a lifetime.
I want you to be able to
master each technique.
You will gain the
confidence and the courage
to express yourself.
I'm Thomas Keller and
this is my MasterClass.